PROFESSOR: Welcome
in this recitation.
So we're going to talk about
linear systems of equations.
So in the first question, we
are given a system of equations.
x dot equals 6x plus 5y.
y dot equals x plus 2y.
We're asked to write this
system in matrix form.
The second part asks us to
convert a differential equation
of second order, x dot dot
plus 8x dot plus 7x equals
to zero into matrix form,
basically into system of ODEs,
similar to the first part.
In the third part
of the problem,
we're asked to
interpret the population
model x dot equals 2x minus
3y, y dot equals x minus y.
So here, x and y are modeling
either a prey or predator.
And you're asked to think
about the interpretation
of the system to
determine which of x or y
is the prey or the predator.
So why don't you
take a few minutes?
Think about these
three questions,
and I'll be right back.
Welcome back.
So for the first
question, basically, we're
asked to write this
system in matrix form.
So we have [x, y] derivative
for that left-hand side.
You need to write this in the
form of a matrix multiplying
x and y.
So here, we would
have 6, 5; 1, 2.
And that would be our system
of differential equations
in matrix form.
And what we would be solving
for would be the vector [x, y].
The second part of the problem,
we need to do the opposite,
go from the second order
differential equation
into matrix form.
So to do that, we introduced a
new variable, y equals x dot.
And from that point,
we can then write
x dot dot-- so if I'm going to
just start with what we know
about the equation,
x dot dot equals--
let me write it in a
system first before I do it
in a vector form.
We would write x dot dot
equals minus 7x minus 8x dot.
But we introduced a new
variable x dot equals 2y.
So we have minus 7x minus 8y.
So now, the other
equation we need
is the one that tells
us what this y is.
So we have x dot equals to
y, which is the new variable
that we introduced here.
And so we go from a second-order
differential equation
into a system of two
differential equations that we
can write now in vectorial
form, in matrix form,
like we did for the first part,
as x, x dot which is just y--
I'm just going to
write this like this,
it's just from what we defined--
equals to, again, [x, y],
like we did previously.
And now we have to
read off our system
to find the coefficient
of this matrix.
So x dot equals to
y means that there
is zero coefficient in front of
the x, a 1 in front of the y.
x dot dot equals minus 7x.
So we will have a minus 7
multiplying the x and minus 8
multiplying the y.
And so that's how we convert
a differential equation,
second order, into the systems
of differential equations
in matrix form.
And this matrix would
be called, referred to,
the companion matrix of
this differential equation.
OK, so that ends
the second part.
So now for the third
question, we're
asked to interpret this
population dynamics
system of equation.
Minus 3y; y dot
equals x minus y.
So the question was,
we have two species.
Which one is the prey,
which one is the predator?
So how do we go about
figuring this out?
Let's look at how
x dot varies with y
or basically variable
x varies with y.
Here, we can see that we have
a coefficient that is minus 3.
It is negative, which means
that when y increases,
we have a more and more
negative x dot, which means
that the value of x goes down.
So as the population
y increases,
we have a decrease
of population x,
which suggests that y
is a predator eating up
population x.
And if you look at the equation
for y, we have x minus y.
And here, what we see is
that when x increases,
the population y then increases.
So that definitely
confirms that y
is our predator that
basically increases
by feeding on the population x.
And as it feeds on
population x, y increases,
which means that here this term
becomes more and more negative,
which means x decreases in turn.
And these two terms could
be modeling, for example,
here just the growth
of the population,
so birth term of the prey.
And these minus y here could
be just modeling, for example,
a death rate of these predators.
And so we have x
prey and y predator.
So from this
recitation, we learned
how to convert a system
of differential equations
to matrix form.
We learned how to convert
a second-order differential
equation into also
matrix form, or basically
system differential
equation, introducing
notion of companion matrix.
And we learned how to interpret
a system of differential
equations in terms of
what populations could it
be modeling or what dynamics
it could be modeling.
So that ends the recitation.